[Musique]
je commence par une confession
c'est vraiment pas facile
choisissez un conseil des ministres je
ne compte plus le nombre de fois ça doit
être la même chose avec toi Martin que
l'autre que je me suis levé la nuit pour
rechanger la liste
François Legault sur la construction du
Conseil des ministres qui va lancer son
second mandat beaucoup d'insomnies donc
mais un cabinet qui s'inscrit tout de
même dans la continuité selon plusieurs
voyons voir ce qu'on passe mes
collaborateurs avec castonguette
animateur de midi info à ici première et
chroniqueur et magazine d'actualité et
Michel CEG est chroniqueur politique à
la presse plus et à Radio-Canada bonjour
à vous trois bonjour bonjour
la référence aux longues nuit de
monsieur Legault Chantal est-ce que
est-ce que ça vous a surpris en fait
qu'est-ce qui vous a surpris dans ce
cabinet là qui ressemble beaucoup quand
même au dernier à bien des égards dans
les gros portefeuilles
ouais et là dessus il y allait pas y
avoir de surprise on le savait déjà sur
la santé et sur les finances ce qui m'a
surpris je pense que personne n'avait vu
venir Bernard Dainville l'éducation et
dans tous les scénarios on n'avait pas
vraiment entendu parler Jean-François
Roberge comme ministre des Affaires
intergouvernementales et donc des
relations canadiennes la principale
personne qui va parler de façon soutenue
au gouvernement fédéral c'est est-ce
qu'ils ont l'un ou l'autre le physique
de l'emploi mais on verra l'usure dans
le cas de monsieur drinville qui a pas
une feuille de route qui ne prépare à ça
en fait moi je pense que Bernard
drinville il y avait la feuille de route
pour être la ministre ses affaires aux
relations canadiennes parce qu'il a
travaillé sur la colline parlementaire
Jean-François Roberge pas de
pas de réseau pas vraiment de
connaissances la machine fédérale
néanmoins au total quand on regarde ça
on se rend compte qu'on a un conseil des
ministres quand même beaucoup plus
expérimenté que la première mouture de
2018 en tout cas c'est pas si bon
j'allais barrette vous aviez vos
questions la semaine dernière j'ai pas
entendu de grosses critiques c'était
Ottawa cette semaine
[Musique]
qui a eu son super ministère mais
monsieur monsieur Legault abarthe une
espèce de comité auquel siège madame
Brochu pour tenter de jouer un peu au
faire le tampon entre les deux est-ce
que ça est-ce que ça va le faire est-ce
que ça va fonctionner
moi j'ai jamais vu de communiquer
ministérielle ou invité le PDG de
l'Hydro-Québec ou n'importe quel autre
compagnie assiéger au même titre que des
ministres ce qui est clair c'est que
monsieur Legault crée qu'il y ait une
rupture entre madame brochute au Québec
et Monsieur il voit pas les choses du
même œil sur l'utilisation des surplus
ou même des stocks d'électricité alors
il a décidé qu'il allait faire des
arbitrages dans ce comité-là plutôt que
d'attendre qu'il y a un problème avant
de faire des arbitrages c'est la seule
explication que je peux donner à ça
c'est assez rare comme comme situation
ça veut dire qu'il tient madame Brochu
d'ailleurs un 10 vendredi bon ben je
continue il y a pas de problème mais
monsieur fait du gamin emmène très large
on le sait ça va être une bonne chose
jusqu'à un certain point pour la Ville
de Montréal qui va voir toujours
utile d'avoir un ami boldozer comme il
faut faire des des dossiers il est bon
par contre il y a plein de dossiers à
Montréal itinérance de logements social
la violence sarahme etc qui sont pas
vraiment dans le carbone me suffit alors
ça a été une semaine avec des plus et
des moins dans son coffret monsieur
Facebook il est l'avantage d'avoir
l'oreille assez direct de monsieur
Legault alors les problèmes montréalais
vont se rendre en haut très rapidement
c'est les évoques si Madame plante les
évoques et Monsieur fatigué Alec on a
l'impression que j'avais l'impression de
regarder ça cette semaine que monsieur
Legault voulait redonner un élan après
deux ans de pandémie à son gouvernement
là on va faire bouger des choses avec
cet équipement est-ce que c'est bon
comment vous voyez ça
d'ailleurs il y a beaucoup de ministres
qui ont rencontré François LEGO à tour
de rôle qui ont dit on s'est fait voler
deux ans et demi de notre mandat il y a
plein de chantiers que j'avais mis en
branle comme ministre que je veux
pouvoir compléter et François Legault
qui déjà aime s'entourer de gens qui
connaissent ne fait pas confiance
facilement François Legault était très
heureux de pouvoir les reconduire dans
leur fonction ou alors partiellement
dans leur fonction pour qu'il puisse
terminer ses chantiers là donc oui il y
a de la continuité mais aussi parce que
les le contexte est particulier celui de
la pandémie et soyons honnête François
Legault ne pas obtenu un mandat de la
population pour rebrasser totalement
l'écart de son conseil des ministres il
y a pas perdu des députés il y a pas
perdu d'un nombre de voix il y a pas
devenu minoritaire il a obtenu un mandat
plus fort donc pas senti de vente
changement dans la population qui dirait
faut que je déplace tout le monde il
faut que je fasse table rase la moitié
du Conseil des ministres alors il était
pas dans cet esprit là et c'est ce que
ça reflète aujourd'hui un petit mot sur
sur pierre fait du début parce que
ce qui est intéressant aussi c'est que
oui puis à fait giber dans l'oreille du
Premier ministre il emmène l'âge mais
déjà dans le précédent mandat il y a des
députés qui se plaignaient parfois de
dire que Pierre fait Dubu d’emmenait
tellement large que par exemple il y
avait des projets de développement
économique dans leur circonscription
dans leur région qui attendaient le feu
vert de Pierrefitte ne voulait pas pour
une raison X débloquer ce projet-là et
là on devait se mettre en petit comité
plusieurs députés il faut convaincre et
à fait du début de dire oui parce que
j'ai besoin de d'une subvention pour
telle entreprise j'ai besoin de telle
chose alors il y en a qui regarde pierre
fait du début super ministre et se
disent ouais c'était pas toujours facile
déjà dans le premier mandat est-ce que
ça va être plus dans le deuxième un pas
certain alors faudrait que tu as fait du
début non seulement soigne un peu ses
relations avec sophie Brochu là il y a
un comité pour l'aider à le faire je
pense que dans sa députation même aussi
devrait être un peu plus à l'écoute
parce que parfois on en avait
l'impression d'un goulot d'étranglement
autour du ministre super puissant et
disons que pour perdu de cette puissance
là dans le remaniement de jeudi des
liens avec les amis du cocu Chantal si
je peux juste revenir sur cette histoire
de comité je pense pas que c'est
seulement un comité pour faire de la
médiation
matrimoniaux anthydro-québec et le
ministre du cabin
pour mener à terme un projet comme un
projet de nouveau barrage comme un
projet de pipeline
choisissez il vous devez mettre à la
même table et en commençant
l'environnement des affaires autochtones
l'économie et si possible dans ce cas-ci
Hydro-Québec ça m'intéresse essentiel et
un arbitre qui s'appelle le Premier
ministre pourquoi parce que les
expériences précédentes l'ont démontré
grandes baleine mais plus récemment
transmonton quand tout le monde n'est
pas à la même table puis tout le monde
tire chacun dans sa direction on arrive
à un échec monumental alors créer ce
comité-là pour surveiller un peu
monsieur fait du Gabin oui mais c'est
aussi un comité qui est essentiel si le
premier ministre est sérieux avec ses
projets de barrage
si ça permet au gouvernement livré plus
rapidement je fais un saut du côté
d'Ottawa cette semaine madame Freeland
en fait était un peu partout à travers
le pays pour aller prononcer des
discours à caractère économique on va
prendre un extrait de ce qu'elle a dit
un peu plus tôt cette semaine puis je
vous reviens tout de suite après
économie va ralentir plusieurs personnes
vont voir leur paiement d'hypothèque
augmentait
les affaires ne seront plus aussi bonnes
que depuis le déconfinement
et le taux de chômage ne sera plus à une
creux historique
[Musique]
on est loin du discours du discours
auquel madame féline nous avait habitué
au cours des derniers mois au WhatsApp
les éléments fondamentaux de l'économie
canadienne sont bonsoir mieux
qu'ailleurs au pays là c'est pas mal
puissant cette semaine qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé la réalité
il y a personne qui croit qu'il y aura
pas de réception toutes les grandes
banques tout le monde qui fait de la
prévision économique dynastie c'est à
nos portes c'est bien beau d'être
optimiste pendant un certain temps mais
là c'est plus possible il est clair que
à la prochaine hausse des taux de la
Banque du Canada ce sont une hausse des
taux majeurs trois quarts de poids
peut-être même un peu plus alors un
moment donné ça va avoir des effets sur
l'économie sur des effets sur la
situation financière du gouvernement ça
veut dire de l'austérité en vue ça veut
dire une récession à vue ça peut être
autre chose
fait parvenir semble-t-il une lettre à
ses collègues en disant si vous voulez
des nouvelles initiatives projets budget
Alec vous allez devoir trouver des sous
dans vos ministères c'est vraiment un
changement de temps on a de la part du
gouvernement libéral est-ce que le
discours de Monsieur Poirier de côté qui
est quand même assez incisif dans ces
attaques sur la gestion de l'économie ce
que ça a pu jouer là-dedans
oui ça doit jouer ça doit jouer
certaines mains le contexte économique
aussi on n'est pas pandémie il faut
repenser équilibrer les livres mais
c'est vrai que c'est un peu contraire
aussi de la maison là
plutôt ça qui était le leitmotique
depuis le début de Justin Trudeau pour
voir là où on avait l'impression qu'on
avait on avait beaucoup d'argent il
manquait des programmes à créer pour
être capable de dépenser là on est dans
un logique un peu inverse ça va être
intéressant de voir si effectivement on
est capable de changer de Cape le danger
pour Christian freelen et c'est pour
tous les politiciens pas seulement pour
elle c'est que l'inflation actuelle dont
elle parle dans ses discours est dû à
trois facteurs donc deux des trois ne
sont pas contrôlés par le gouvernement
les taux d'intérêt les banques centrales
vont faire leur travail essayer de
diminuer la consommation jouer sur la
demande mais les deux autres facteurs
c'est la difficulté des chaînes
d'approvisionnement logistiques post
pandémie sur le gouvernement peut pas y
faire grand chose et la guerre en
Ukraine non plus et donc le problème le
danger pour les gouvernements à Ottawa
comme c'est de dire les banques
centrales augmentent les taux d'intérêt
pour juguler l'inflation si ça ne
fonctionne pas si l'inflation reste très
élevée parce que les deux autres
facteurs eux ne bougent pas ça va
devenir très casse-gueule pour les
gouvernements alors j'ai hâte de voir
son incapable de tenir cette ligne là
pendant encore des mois ça va être
intéressant c'est vraiment une période
très très incertaine pour les
gouvernements à travers le monde puis le
gouvernement canadien
cette semaine c'est ce qu'elle a dit à
Washington la semaine passée sur l'idée
d'accélérer des prochaines
développements pétroliers minier c'était
plus là on m'a soufflé à l'oreille cette
semaine que bureau du premier ministre
avait été un peu surpris par cette
portion là du discours de Madame féline
la semaine passée pourquoi au juste
l'addition pourquoi il le dit plus
elle le pense encore et ça veut dire ce
que fort d'être la ligne de conduire du
gouvernement parce que c'est aussi ce
que le ministre des choses naturelles
monsieur Wilkinson dit c'est le
processus d'approbation de projet prend
trop de temps et le contexte de la
guerre en Ukraine les arguments de
Pierre Poirier des conservateurs qui
disent c'est mieux d'en produire plus
pour remplacer du méchant charbon que de
s'asseoir sur nos mains et de laisser
l'Europe s'approvisionner ou retourner
vers le charbon vers des carburants qui
sont produits dans des conditions encore
moins avantageuses ça a plus de poids
autour de la table du Conseil des
ministres que précédemment ça a
certainement fait sursauté Steven gateau
et autres et ce qui aurait amené le
bureau du premier ministre à dire on
peut tempérer ça mais enfin leur nous le
7 Eddy ça n'a pas été dédié
pour autant il y a pas eu de mise au
point j'ai lu une longue entrevue avec
Justin Trudeau sur la lutte au
changement climatique où il dit on va
les atteindre nos objectifs et il disait
pas on va pas approuver de projet encore
gênant de toute façon un viande
d'approuver B du Nord avec les mêmes
arguments que ceux que Madame Freeland
avance ouais effectivement d'ailleurs
monsieur Guilbaud qu'on avait l'émission
un peu plus tôt
était clairement pas sur la même
longueur d'onde mais trouver une façon
d'expliquer ça un peu il y a des moyens
d'accélérer pour le processus enfin on
verra ce que ça va donner un mot sur les
audiences de commission rouleau avec
qu'est-ce qu'on a une semaine d'audience
maintenant un peu plus d'une semaine il
s'est dit pas mal de choses cette
semaine il y a eu des déclarations assez
fracassantes qu'est-ce que vous avez
retenu de cette première semaine de
travaux
bon il reste encore quand même quelques
semaines d'audience mais c'est assez
clair que pour l'instant la
désorganisation des forces de police
était-elle que on ne peut pas se dire il
y avait une raison de justifier
l'utilisation de la Loi sur les mesures
d'urgence est-ce qu'à la fin des
audiences on va dire la même chose
lorsqu'on va avoir entendu des ministres
parce qu'on va avoir entendu la haute
fonction publique je le sais pas mais
pour l'instant le compte-rendu du
terrain le maire d'Ottawa la police
montre que on n'était pas prêt et on
n'avait pas les outils pour faire face à
ce type de manifestation là malgré tous
les signes avant-coureurs et c'est ce
qui est fascinant on savait qu'on
voulait s'incruster pendant des jours
voir des semaines les chambres d'hôtel
étaient réservées pour un mois le convoi
est parti de la Colombie Britannique il
y a prix 8 10 jours avant de se rendre
tout le monde tout le long des caméras
disait on va s'installer on va
s'installer puis Ottawa on était surpris
que les gens parfois après 24-48 heures
alors écoute ça puis tu dis ouais c'est
eux qui aurait dû être capable de gérer
la situation est-ce qu'il aurait été
capable le en tout cas il est placé
actuellement effectivement Chantal
est-ce que les forces policières ont
démontré cette semaine et les élus
municipaux de la région d'Ottawa c'est
que ils auraient dû faire partie de la
solution et que finalement ils ont
vraiment fait partie du programme et ce
faisant ils ont donné des arguments
favorables à la décision du centre
Trudeau parce que la question c'est pas
dans l'abstrait est-ce qu'il y aurait eu
moyen de faire autrement dans l'abscès
oui à Québec qu'on a empêchait des
camions d'envahir le centre ville de
Québec la vraie question c'est dans le
concret dans le réel de ce qui s'est
passé là est-ce qu'il y avait moyen de
faire autrement que d'invoquer la loi
sur des mesures d'urgence ben si on a ça
en été remis à la pagaille entre les
forces de police et
l'incompétence parce qu'on peut parler
d'incompétence peut-être que on aurait
transformé la colline parlementaire de
dans les années 70 dans le temps de la
commission mec dans le monde de partager
de l'information de la regarder ensemble
de se faire une tête chacun garde son
petit bout d'information pour lui comme
si c'était quelque chose de bien
précieux surtout pas le partager avec
l'autre police et un moment donné ça
fait exactement le genre de fiasco qu'on
a vu et ça fait en sorte que là tout
d'un coup il y a un paquet de police qui
doivent débarquer en tout cas on verra
si c'est la Commission va déterminer
parce que ça a duré quand même il y a
encore quoi 5 semaines le témoignage le
chauffeur là-dessus c'est tout le temps
qu'il nous reste Alex Chantal Michel
merci infiniment d'avoir été là la
semaine prochaine
on va voir